we're here at
pumpkin plays long island to settle some
very
important halloween debates
couples costumes adorable or atrocity
atrocities
they're adorable i really like them well
have you ever been part of a couple's
costume
i was a firefighter in a dalmatian oh
that's
cute i would say adorable you know but
they can be atrocious sometimes
atrocity got a boy sir
if you like couples costumes then stay
lit
candy corn disgusting or delicious
disgusting disgusting delicious it's my
favorite
i hate candy corn i love it disgusting
so you guys have some things to work
through before halloween
sir do you like candy corn good or
disgusting
disgusting i agree team chocolatey candy
or team fruity chewy candy candy
chocolatey candy chocolatey fruity chewy
candy
chocolate how do spiders communicate
on the world wide web yeah
now we're doing a pumpkin spice speed
round
you tell me if it's nice or no dice
pumpkin spice kale chips no dice no dice
no no no dice eel pumpkin spice butter
nice yeah nice dice no dice nice
no no eels pumpkin spice salsa
no dice no no resounding
pumpkin spice lasagna no no no dice
no eel pumpkin spice
moonshine i would like that yeah
i'll definitely building control i have
a bathtub full in my apartment
it's interesting thank you and i think i
can guess this one
pumpkin spice moonshine
[Music]
all right good following the law i
appreciate that santino thank you so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
much